sundar Pichai
iOS when we talk about our two large
computing platforms open platforms
Android and Chrome as of this CSI Oh
Android tablets account for sixty-two
percent of the overall market at the
beginning of last year we had 27 million
monthly active users of Chrome on mobile
today we have more than 300 million what
if pixels didn't just have color but
also depth what if there was an
intelligent material that was a simplest
paper but could transform and change
shape in response to touch and this led
us to way of thinking that we call
material design so battery saver is
really great if you're about to embark
on a long hike or maybe a long protest
and you say you want the battery to last
even longer the LG G watch to Samsung's
gear lives the Moto 360 is the first
watch to adopt the rond Android where
you I today we're announcing Android TV
with outdoor TV we decided to build a
course search functionality directly
into the experience powered by voice who
played Katniss and The Hunger Games and
of course the answer is Jennifer
Lawrence played Katniss Everdeen in The
Hunger Games we've redesigned the
Android platform for automotive
navigation communication how late is the
deyoung museum open today the young
museum is open from 930am to 5 15 p.m.
on wednesday anybody play some music
android auto puts these front and center
so you don't have to go hunting through
a grid of icons to find the apps that
are most important to you when you're in
the car